good morning John's Tuesday some day of
some month I also think I need to get
off my chest as well good I said mine's
everybody's done those are Mars it's
just not news that there's ice on Mars
why is that news we've known for like 50
years that there's ice on Mars okay
[Music]
sorry
Mars dork ours has ice caps there
sometimes coated with carbon dioxide
like dry ice but at the core they're
both made of water I don't know why
everyone thought that it was news that
there's ice on Mars the news is that the
lander landed on ice that's great news
for the people who wanted to study the
eggs but there always been eyes up ours
anyway a couple weeks ago I asked the
nerdfighters to use their collective
brain cells in googling fingers to
answer some questions and they did a
remarkably good job answering all but
one of the questions in the one question
that didn't get answered was pretty hard
and I asked what the difference between
mono and uni were and you guys knew that
apparently the big difference is that
one is Latin and one is Greek and I
thought they were both Latin Latin words
use uni and Greek words use mono now are
there are other people who indicated
that uni often had a connotation of
bringing many into one whereas mono was
just one on its own like monomer is one
thing all by itself whereas university
is many coming into one but that doesn't
work in every circumstance like unicycle
still only has one wheel it's not a mono
cycle but interesting nonetheless if
you're interested in that coming
continuing trivia comes from trivia I
was right trivia three roads and any
place where three roads come together is
often where people get together and talk
about things gossip you know chill out
hang out talk about you stuff doesn't
really matter not very important stuff
but you know trivia are there more
murders on TV or in real life elderly
it's pretty much done answered the
general consensus is that real life
probably has more murders which Chino
and that what I would want to hear per
capita television definitely has more
murders if your character on television
your life span is significantly shorter
than a percent of your life also if
you're at a party and Tony Shalhoub or
Angela Lansbury or hercule poirot show
up just leave Leave leave run away
because either your jewels are gonna get
stolen or you are gonna get locked I
also asked whether evil people have pet
lots of evil people have had pets so a
lot of people know about Hitler he had a
dog named blondie a German Shepherd
surprised that apparently went down the
same way as he and his girlfriend threw
poison pill but what you may not know is
that Hitler had another dog named Fuchs
I'm not making it up so while Hitler was
fighting in World War one he was he was
a work around the trenches and he found
a little Terrier named Fuchs and he
adopted it and later Fuchs was stolen
from him whoever stole Fuchs
may in fact have been responsible for
hit but turning out the way he did
probably not nonetheless it's hard to
think but if you had a little terrier
named Fuchs that you could be that much
of a jerk Fuchs
let him go cats he had lots of cats and
while you may not think that one is very
evil you did sort of open up the door
for Stalin to take over after he died
which not good however there are some
people that really hated pets for
example mal who you might not think is
all that evil until I tell you this
story decided that all pets were a
symbol of both wars the oppression and
had them all killed in the 60s and 70s
he killed tens of thousands of dogs and
cats even dogs and cats that were raised
primarily for food he killed those as
well not that they would not have died
so now you know the answers to all those
questions I have a question for you I'm
making a song about Star Trek and it's
longer than four minutes and I can't get
it any shorter if I'm going to have to
impose the one longer than four minutes
clause and that requires that there be a
nerdfighting
montage so if you can send me anything
to do with Star Trek anything
thirdly next generation and preferably
with Captain Picard involved that'll be
fantastic news sports life at gmail.com
so that the video can be longer than
four minutes I promise it'll be worth it
very excited about the song John I'll
see you soon
Lenin's kitty says click the little
yellow box and subscribe